c'était il ya une semaine la ville de
vire ont été sidérés défiguré touché au
vif à 18h09 pour marquer le moment les
terribles les images captées à l'instant
où tout a basculé était projeté sur un
écran géant face au port détruit ya
plusieurs sentiments qui se mélangent
sentiment de haine pour cette classe
politique corrompue
les criminels qu'ils ont qui nous ont
torturés cee la cause de cette explosion
sentiment de haine de tristesse pour les
victimes de compassion pour les familles
des victimes et les familles des blessés
et ceux qui ont perdu plusieurs membres
de la famille et qui ont perdu leur
maison comme vous pouvez le voir
partout dans beyrouth à travers la peine
pour ce qui n'est plus et le mépris d'un
état absent une dose de reconnaissance
les pompiers premier arrivé sur la scène
de l'incendié encore avant la double
explosion un pays un lourd tribut ils
ont été salués en héros par la foule
ils étaient nombreux et de toutes
confessions confondues rassembler c'est
la nation dont il rêve ici mais qui
continue de leur échapper c'est un
moment de recueillement collectif à la
mémoire des victimes qui survient alors
que la blessure est toujours vive pour
certains la plaie est toujours béante la
peur encore les morts la famille d'amy
hleb a passé la semaine qui vient de
s'écouler à le chercher a demandé de ses
nouvelles en vers il travaillait dans le
port de beyrouth sont atteints on leur a
enfin remis le reste de son corps mutilé
tous se sont retrouvés non pas dans un
mais dans trois hôpitaux de berry n'a
rien ne peut nous apaiser dit son oncle
nous avons perdu un être cher que dieu
accompagne les familles des victimes
les blessés et ceux qui manquent
toujours ensevelies sous les décombres
ils n'ont pas l'intention de les
déterrer ajoute-t-il parlant des
autorités
c'est un martyr se dit sa famille pour
se consoler morts pour une cause que
l'on veut pas croire perdu la démission
en bloc du gouvernement est un tout
petit pas timide dans la bonne direction
dit on mais c'est tout le système qui
pourvu que son changement à la
constitution les libanais ont envie de
se retrouver avec une copie du
gouvernement qui viennent tomber dit on
dans la foule
vous savez au liban on a sept dictateur
dans certains pays où ils ont un seul
dictateur
ça leur prend des années et des années
et des années pour faire chuter le
régime
au liban on a sept dictateur donc c'est
d'autant plus dur je sais pas ça à
prendre cette fois plus de temps pour
les faire chuter
mais c'est beaucoup plus dur donc donc
ouais faut remplir les rues les rues
faux-pas caisses vides du tout
regardez la pression on aime la paix ces
deux là compte sur les jeunes
ce qui encore ce soir brûle de rage et
tous de l'absence d'horizon
parce que les morts eux ne peuvent plus
rien si mario bédard radio canada